This is Station eleven site two about to commence. Well that was the fellowship and that was the kind of work.
It did it cared about the people and just in finishing off. If you put it very it was a very interesting experience.
First of all. The state elections were coming out. And at that time it was a Labor government.
This was before the eschaton government. Had passed. And we got into care and Caroline Street in Redfern.
At the situation. And we went over there with an ethic pencils painted. Cardboard.
And we spent an evening making posters. And. Someone said where and when are we going to use this. Ourselves Grace.
We will go to the Labor Party. Night the public meeting when they opened their campaign for the elections.
And it will be out in America. HALL I think. But I have to check and.
So we were very excited about that and those of us who had cast in all the cars with people from marriage.
And many of the Labor Party people came on that night and the premier at the time was Catholic.
It isn't and wasn't here for and it was premier after different electorate around the world. Those places.
Will go down with their placards. And packed with labor support.
So there's no way to put up their placards silently and quietly and we learn one whole wall. Oh before we left greed.
There would be no interjections nothing just stand silently and hold their placards.
Well we'll line the whole wall up the meeting place.
And the Labor Party people who are looking him throwing curses black looks at us. You know.
It was pressed to see these people with a placard. And. He couldn't contain it. So he couldn't.
And out of the blue when the premier was addressing the meeting.
He moved into the center of the hall holding his plaque at high above it.
And it was before we were able to change the way. Which discriminated against the preacher or people and his place.
Parliament. Has about. Have they got a color. And he walked out and he said what about us.
At the top of his voice and he was a big man. It was so affected so affected.
And I think that was one of the most effective of most effective of all the demonstrations we have a Hilde.
Now you come back to the fact that see. The referendum was held for cats who was very well established.
And we had four branches in the various states and yourself whilst braincell.
And the Braintree would carry a secretary who would sit on the federal executive of.
So that was that contact with the local groups and for Kathy. And these people secretaries.
It was amazing that in such a short after the Federal Council was formed.
That a greater come from the grassroots right throughout Australia.
Darwin got very active on the matter of equal wages. And.
People who were aware that there was an organisation in existence. That was carried people who were pretty sincere.
And who also had contacts in the federal parliament. And I think they were aware also.
The very fact that they didn't preach religion they didn't preach. Anything.
And they did their best always to have representation from. What was known and then as the Aboriginal.
Conferences if they were held. So. The conference to start it off was held.
I think to start for kept to yourself I think was held like a like part of the year
but I think from then on it was held all the way at least a tad. And so for seventeen years.
I gave up my east to attend conferences.
And there were times when hams and the children would come over it all hop into the car and they'd go camping
and wandering around Canberra and that kind of thing and. Just the conference.
But the first conference after it was formed was held in Melman then Sydney
and we were moving out you know we could feel we were growing. And the conference in verse.
And he made no special favors regardless of what color you were. You had to understand that you were in business.
And you had to abide by the laws of the meeting.
And it didn't matter who is holding the floor or the person it was black or white. It's Times that was just absolutely.
Well. And that was the third country after its formation. There appeared a woman.
In a yellow bright yellow cotton dress. Tiny.
And many Aboriginal people just a few Some had come to say what conditions were like on the east.
And there was someone from the Terrible. Another one who'd come from Box Hill.
A terrible place where the people who are virtually imprisoned
and like coming from North Queensland including one who became president. And that was Joe McGinniss.
And we had a university in which to meet.
But this woman in the US who was pretty vocal and it turned out to be careful. And.
I think in many ways that was the most important conference up to date because it stretched into a state that was
relatively. By the likes of the people who made up for a party conference after sixty or sixty one.
And there was a bit of a delegation from the North Queensland and it was a woman I shall never forget in her name.
Ah was Ruth. WALLACE. And she went to recession that had to do you know.
She got up and she went out front and she told her she was taken away.
And how she was put to work in a fishing factory where you boned fish and. Prepared for canning I suppose.
And how she got a fish bone in her finger. And she never got the fish. She probably would have lived and died.
As a taken away. And she was. She said that finger gave me my freedom.
Because apparently she was taken to the hospital and from there. She was taken out into the world as it were.
It was an amazing story and she held up her little finger and she said my little finger gave me my freedom.
I think I just stopped because I'm not over.